okay
um let's now talk about Donald Trump's
plan
that he has made clear is his plan to
announce his candidacy on Tuesday uh at
Mar-A-Lago Donald Trump talking about uh
initially that he might announce in Ohio
he then decided that that is not what he
is going to do and then in Ohio he
actually said we are going to make the
announcement on November 15th so let's
go through this step by step starting
with what Trump first teased in Florida
a few days ago about Ohio take a listen
I will probably have to to do it again
but stay tuned
okay so then the Crouch yours for a
while then Trump says the following
[Applause]
that's pretty good thank you
stay tuned
to tomorrow night in the great state of
Ohio stay tuned we have a big we have a
big rally there okay so then people
thought he's going to announce tomorrow
he's going to announce tomorrow did not
happen because tomorrow which was Monday
Donald Trump decided the announcement
will be next Tuesday
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida
[Applause]
so as recently as yesterday Donald Trump
was appearing on TV and still saying
I'm gonna do it this is the latest
all right well we're talking about your
announce I do want to bring up something
a lot of people been talking about
you've had
this this is not sped up by the way this
is normal speed last year are huge
rallies that we've seen we've covered
many of them here on Newsmax but you you
said that you're going to do this at
Mar-A-Lago on November 15th why the
significance of announcing at Mar-A-Lago
well I actually would have preferred
doing it at a rally but I didn't want to
take away from JD I didn't want to take
away from anybody else that you know was
at the particular rally even Marco
Israeli was so great it was unbelievable
in Miami right and I would have
preferred it and then I said you know I
take away I also take away maybe from
the day which is today because you know
you're talking about a big announcement
so I just felt that maybe it was better
off doing it where it's by itself a
little bit and it's just a few days
actually one week exactly one week later
and a lot of people are going to be
there but I I really like the idea of
doing it at a rally because you know
when you have 40 50 000 people and you
make that kind of an announcement and
they're all saying do it do it they're
screaming last night do it but uh so
what I did last night is that I'm going
to do it we're going to make a really I
think statement that people are going to
be very happy about yeah so the question
now becomes do the results from last
night change this plan if you're Trump I
don't think they do because Trump is the
endless narcissist as we all know I
think you can't sit Trump down and say
listen sir as he always claims people
say to him
um you engaged you uh engaged you
endorsed Tudor Dixon she lost badly
you endorsed uh Dr Oz he lost you
endorsed Doug mastriano he lost you
endorse Blake Masters in Kerry Lake TBD
TBD we don't know what's going on there
you endorsed Herschel Walker
as of this moment he's losing it will
probably go to a runoff and then who
goes what's going to happen who knows
what's going to happen
it's not great and sure you endorsed
like a hundred incumbents and they won
but incumbents tend to win that's not
really a big deal maybe you should
consider not running I don't know that
even if you show Trump the numbers I
just showed you in the last segment and
show Trump what folks since the last
segment I think Ron DeSantis has
potentially even gained a little bit and
you show Trump listen the betting
markets increasingly say it is going to
be Ron DeSantis not you if this is a
contested nomination
I don't even know that in that case
you necessarily can convince Trump not
to do it it is clear that what was
previously a silent feeling within some
of the Republican party that Trump is
bad for the party is becoming a more
publicly acknowledged feeling whether it
actually changes Trump's plans next week
I don't know if indeed the announcement
happens we will cover it live and make
sure folks this this is the start of an
insane two-year period at minimum please
make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel more than 3 million
people watch our clips and don't
subscribe we need everybody on board for
what's coming over the next two years in
the defense of the Democracy that we
must carry out make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube we're going to
take a quick break and be right back
before you go if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more please make sure to
subscribe to my YouTube channel you can
click the Subscribe button below or
above or wherever it is on your screen
and if you want to support my work even
more strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description